[Musique]
tous les départs sur semblent ou
celui-ci il a un goût un peu particulier
pour vous c'est toujours un petit moment
à la fois de d'excitation et puis de
d'appréhension aussi l'équipage apprend
à se connaître depuis l'été et le Rotary
et on se lève toujours aussi tôt dans la
marine
on aime bien faire les choses auto et le
travail de nuit est une des
particularités du travail et c'est et
voir l'aube comme ça Brest ça reste un
plaisir
les marins disent que même le plus petit
de leur bateau est un bout de France en
mer
[Musique]
on a beau être à marin confirmé
l'appareillage d'une frégate a comme un
air de rituel
[Musique]
tout d'abord on va se décoller en
mettant à gauche toute tribord avant 0
et la RT à compte donc
180% l'idée c'est de viser une position
à peu près 10 mètres du quai voilà pour
garder suffisamment d'eau sur tribord
[Musique]
deux machines à vendre
%
[Musique]
l'Aquitaine est un des fers de lance de
la marine française
ces nouvelles frégates sont considérées
comme les plus importants bâtiment de
surface d'une flotte de guerre
d'abord une centaine de membres
d'équipage des marins formés aux
équipements de dernière génération
[Musique]
sont arrêtés les pompes de bar numéro
une de chaque bar sont en fonction
et je monte dans les tours de car à la
barre pour soulager les manœuvriers leur
donner de l'aide là
le bateau
sous les ordres du chef du car le cap
qui m'a donné là par exemple c'est le
267 et moi je j'essaye de tenir au mieux
le cap de 167 en donnant des angles de
barre à gauche puis à droite avec le
joystick
le fait que tout soit automatisé comme
ça c'est quoi c'est un confort de
travail oui c'est un confort de travail
je peux rester tout un quart en gare de
route et juste seulement si le cap
change changer avec mon joystick après
le fait d'être en manuel aussi ça fait
passer le temps plus vite donc ça dépend
des fois
qui est plutôt agréable
donc là vous pouvez prévenir le qn on
réduit en allure et on va déployer cette
semaine l'équipage doit subir une série
d'évaluations une remise à niveau
opérationnelle un passeport
incontournable pour partir en mission et
justement selon les marins les tensions
en mer n'ont jamais été aussi élevées la
mer est un milieu fluide dans lequel on
peut circuler librement et par exemple
nous aujourd'hui sur les bâtiments de la
Marine nationale nous croisons très
régulièrement
nos compétiteurs et que donc la
situation qui est assez instable en ce
moment elle peut à tout moment basculer
d'un côté ou de l'autre comme le dit le
chef d'état-major de la Marine en mer
sur un bateau de bâtiment de la Marine
nationale le temps de crise et le temps
de guerre finalement
ne tient qu'à cause reçoit
alors ce qui est certain c'est que tous
les grands pays et les grandes
puissances du monde réarme leur marine à
une vitesse assez importante
en quantité qu'en qualité d'ailleurs et
ensuite on voit bien que la mer est
aussi
l'espace par lequel transit toutes les
richesses et tout le commerce mondial et
également
sous les mers transit les fameux câbles
dont on a dont on entend souvent parler
par lesquelles transit toutes les
informations Internet par exemple et qui
peuvent susciter beaucoup de convoitises
je préviens la machine et après il sert
juste à tenir le bateau bouge pas trop
et qu'on est bien comme ça et si ça
commence à partir d'un mois ou deux vous
montrer pour voir ce que c'est reçu
au fond de couloir
donc on va arriver dans la course
la frégate est un navire de guerre
susceptible de répondre à toutes les
missions de combat sur l'échiquier naval
c'est une pièce maîtresse du grand large
et à en croire les marins elle est
taillée pour les chocs les plus durs
donc là on arrive sur le roof VRS c'est
d'ici quand ils vont partir les
différents missiles donc il y a
plusieurs types de missiles il y a les
asters et les MDCN donc les asters c'est
ce qui va nous permettre de faire de la
lutte anti-aérienne donc de traiter une
menace qui arrive donc que ce soit
directement le porteur donc un avion un
hélicoptère ou toute menaces aérienne
emdcn lui il va nous servir plus à faire
des frappes contre terre donc c'est des
missiles qui sont tirés depuis la mer
jusqu'à la terre qui vient de porter
très importante et qui vont nous
permettre par exemple de frapper un
point à une distance assez importante
donc qui vont nous donner vraiment un
avantage sur l'ennemi c'est de nous
rester en sécurité tout en frapper
actuellement quand on est en exercice
comme comme maintenant est-ce qu'on en
porte des munitions réelles on va voir
toujours des munitions réelles puisque
même si là on est en exercice et si on
s'entraîne on est toujours susceptible
de basculer directement sur une
opération donc surtout en ce moment avec
les niveaux de crise un peu partout dans
le monde pas capable de réagir très vite
d'autant plus que en fait on est
entraînement on est toujours aussi un
peu en mission parce que on fait du
renseignement
[Musique]
sur
les étiquettes
ici
[Musique]
à ses mains
une frégate en exercice embarque à son
bord des entraîneurs des marins aguerris
envoyés par l'état major aujourd'hui ces
hommes au brassard jaune ont écrit un
scénario pas si éloigné du réel le décor
un navire suspect les personnages des
marins armés jusqu'aux dents
il y aura facilement une prise de
contact radio avec lui sur VHF pour lui
demander pourquoi il n'apporte pas de
pavillon et puis ensuite effectivement
il y aura un compte rendu fait vers
notre contrôle
[Musique]
sans mettre sur l'avant du client tout
ça d'abord on regarde d'abord 2 8 4
nickel le 7 buts reconnu comment
directeur but fictif reconnu sans mettre
sur l'avant du client des pointages
vérifié
alerte
[Musique]
à droite elle tire la réflexe
du côté d'abord
[Musique]
caché qui pourrait être dangereux parce
qu'après quand on va aller palper on va
les mettre dans une zone qui va être
sécurisé pour nous donc là en fait on a
rassemblé il y a une masse il y a une
barre en métal tout ce qui pourrait
servir en fait à nous frapper avec pour
éviter si jamais il se rebelle en fait
qu'il faisait de quoi nous blesser
[Musique]
OK
Google
c'est une arme pour l'exercice
qui était découvert qui était en
détention illégale on n'a pas la preuve
que ils avaient des documents proposés
quand même provisoirement pour éviter
parce que ce sont quand même dangereux
et puis c'est pas possible on les garde
quand même en rétention
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années la contestation
du droit en mer est un phénomène en
constante augmentation pour les marins
ces opérations de contrôle sont
fréquentes
comment on fait évoluer les doctrines
d'entraînement par rapport au conflit
qu'on rencontre par rapport à
l'actualité par rapport au retour
d'expérience des opérations qu'on
conduit donc avant tout on cherche à
mettre nos mains dans des situations
basiques
on recherche le drill les actions
fondamentales qui doivent connaître
parce qu'au combat c'est ce sont bien
ces actions fondamentales et ses
réflexes c'est un peu pavloviens qui
vont qui vont faire que du coup l'action
sera efficace ensuite on cherchera à les
mettre en situation d'inconfort et puis
on les met face souvent à des canons
conformes bon tout type de situation
la frégate et le bâtiment le plus
déployé en haute mer alors la Marine
nationale a entièrement renouvelé sa
flotte de frégate multimissions capable
de naviguer en autonomie sous toutes les
latitudes Olivier a connu les longues
traversées et les anciens bateaux moins
confortables
bienvenue chez moi alors ici on va
retrouver mon poste donc c'est là où les
marins vont avoir leur espace personnel
et vont se pouvoir se reposer donc si on
va retrouver donc une banette c'est
notre seul espace d'intimité à bord on
va pouvoir un peu se retrouver quand on
est en mission on compare longtemps
merde ou est-ce que vous rangez vous à
faire
on va retrouver nos caissons de
rangement
un caisson exactement ça fait pas
beaucoup
c'est vrai que ça fait pas beaucoup mais
on a l'habitude d'optimiser dans la
marine
combien de jours de mer un marin peut-il
naviguer dans une année alors ça dépend
ça c'est particulier pour ce bâtiment là
parce qu'on va retrouver deux équipages
qui vont se relier toute l'année et en
fait on va prendre le bateau 6 mois dans
l'année donc six mois on va être à terre
et six mois on sera sur le bateau et
généralement l'équipage qui a le bateau
va être en mer
la plupart du temps finalement c'est un
bateau plutôt confortable exactement on
a une vraie plus-value par rapport aux
anciens bateaux
[Musique]
4 du matin la faux soit avoir une bonne
tailleur soit avoir une bonne équipe de
passerelles parce que le temps est un
peu long il faut pas s'endormir quoi
mais
et en fait moi c'était la vie d'aventure
qui m'a surtout bouger j'avais pas envie
de me retrouver dans un bureau
mamie je suis un grand rêveur donc
j'avais un peu envie aussi de
me dire voilà j'ai aussi un peu vécu pas
que dans mes rêves mais en vrai des
choses assez incroyables
j'ai envie d'être utile d'avoir un
métier qui a un peu de sens et là
aujourd'hui on est vraiment repassé dans
une logique où comme les conflits
reviennent il y a vraiment des risques
il faut être conscient de ces risques
pour aller jusqu'au bout de la mission
finalement c'est ça c'est pourquoi on a
signé c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout de la
mission
[Musique]
on a le clairon mais on soit enfin notre
outil de musique personnalisée c'est
plutôt pas mal ambiance dans l'équipage
tourne soit un peu de bonne humeur le
matin musique
tout de suite le point météo du jour le
ciel sera coupé
et nous aurons de bonnes décisions
vous sentez cette odeur de poudre qui
m'attroupe la fille
de 12,7 20 mm 76 ça va faire du bruit ah
ben tu forum national
[Musique]
35 de nautique 5
00 pieds
à la différence de la guerre sur terre
le combat en mer est souvent hors de
porter des caméras pourtant la bataille
navale n'a pas disparu désormais elle
fait appel à des technologies de pointe
et pour conserver l'avantage une frégate
doit posséder les meilleurs systèmes de
combat
donc pour l'instant ils sont pas
agressif on lance toujours focus sur
leur changement de comportement ça forme
un comportement plus agressif à l'avenir
à la prochaine passe on entendra
directement le warning de Alpha
l'opération donc c'est ce qui va
regrouper l'ensemble des censeurs à bord
et ce qui va permettre de mettre en
œuvre tous les systèmes donc que ce soit
ici torpille on va retrouver tout ce qui
est radar sonore
de 70 ache le lasters
[Musique]
avec des capacités de détection très
très bonne on va voir très loin donc on
va détecter tout ce qu'il y a sous la
mer on va le classifier et dans le cas
d'une menace on va l'engager
très vite cette très concis et précis
sinon
il suffit d'une seconde inattention pour
pour créer la photo
la frégate multimission est un bâtiment
de combat capable de se reconfigurer en
fonction de la mission
ce jour-là l'exercice n'a rien d'une
fiction si Brieuc et concentré c'est
qu'il est évalué et que les tirs sont
bien réels
donc au large de Billy
justement les spécialistes de l'armée de
terre qui nous donne la position d'une
cible
[Musique]
avec le DAO enfin nous il nous entend
plus donc on supprime la base de tiens
pour le moment fin de couplage à toi
dans l'accin
de CPC
le terrien du coup on a avorté
on a avorté la séquence on va se
retourner attendre d'être bien contacté
avec eux il faut être absolument contact
avec eux donc c'est eux qui vont nous
permettre de recaler dans ce que les
mauvaises visibilité mais si on n'a pas
de contact avec le dlo et si on n'a pas
de contact avec celui qui nous ordonne
le feu on sait pas quand est-ce qu'on va
ouvrir on sait pas s'il y a un danger
proximité et on sait pas si c'est bon
pour eux
temps de vol temps de vol 38 secondes
[Musique]
l'objectif donc l'objectif a été détruit
donc mission accomplie et voilà donc là
on est en train de dérober grande
vitesse pour se mettre à l'abri
tu fais le déroulement jusqu'à être en
dehors de la FSA et ensuite
[Musique]
mes meilleurs vœux de pouvoir faire les
effets
si les marins ont intensifié leur
entraînement c'est que la perspective
d'un combat naval n'est plus une simple
hypothèse
on entend beaucoup qu'il faut repenser
le combat naval pourquoi faut-il
repenser le combat naval aujourd'hui
depuis à peu près une trentaine d'années
on s'entraîne de manière très sérialisée
pour être sûr que les équipages ont
acquis les savoir-faire basique c'est
d'ailleurs ce que nous sommes en train
de faire en ce moment dans le cadre de
notre stage de remise à niveau
opérationnelle mais maintenant ça ne
suffit plus le réarmement des Marines
internationales à la gare en Ukraine
font que il faut qu'on s'entraîne à
l'incertitude de combat
d'où la modification et la
transformation de la préparation
opérationnelle des bâtiments qui se
tourne dans la préparation
opérationnelle haute intensité voilà il
faut absolument habitu équipage à penser
autrement à prendre des risques
autrement et à gérer l'incertitude du
combat
[Musique]
alors que la mer est ses richesses sont
désormais l'objet de toutes les
convoitises les rapports de force se
multiplient au large dans ce contexte
les espaces maritimes ont repris une
importance stratégique
[Musique]
un visuel visuel alignement avec la
boule l'homme jaune devant la bouée là
une tempête
[Musique]
depuis ce tournage l'équipage de
l'Aquitaine a rejoint sa zone
d'opération quelque part en mer Baltique
une région redevenue une zone de tension
sur la scène internationale une mère
froide coincée entre la Russie et les
pays baltes
[Musique]
de ma chérie